everyone has a problem with time  but  the day is 24 hours  and we sleep six  now i know there are some out there that  say whoa whoa i need eight  well i say just sleep a little faster  because the bottom line is we have  six hours of sleep 24 hours are  available so if 18 hours now available  to your work  your family  your hobbies  and also to learn something new or to do  something new which could easily be that  you want to learn a new language  or that you want to read and as a  new year's resolution i have to read a  book every week or you say i'm going to  go and reshape my body  so you're gonna go and take this hour  out of your schedule and say i'm gonna  train an hour every day so this is for  most people a huge challenge but it is  totally doable i can tell them